شايف هذه البلكه اللي قبالك شايفها انا
بصفيها صفيها شرب ولادي في منها ميه فشه
كهرب فشه كل حاجه فشه هذا بجيب كيله
وصفيها على الوجه الوجه باخذها وبشرب ودي
منها لان هي صالحه شرب غيرها مش صالح هي
عطشان الولد هذا الولد عطشان ايش بنعمل
احنا ايش بنسوي ايش بنعمل هذا ب الشتاء لو
مش ش الدنيا بنموت من عطش بنموت احنا من
عطش لو ما شش الدنيا علينا بنموت من العطش
بنشفق تبعون الجنوب اللي تدمر من الشتاء
ونفس الو ققول اه كويس نا عشان احنا نعيش
شوف ربنا منزلنا الشتاء هذا عشان نشرب منه
احنا فهمت كيف ربنا منزلنا الشتا عشان
نشرب ايش نعمل ايش نسوي فيش ابار كله
قصفها اول حاجه بلشوا في الابار يقفوها
والكهربا والدنيا والدين احنا مين بالنسبه
لاتانيا
واحنا